welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and secret invasion is a new marvel
series coming to disney plus hopefully
sometime soon we just got our first
official look at this series from disney
plus day which is really just a title in
one to two seconds of grizzled badass
looking nick fury not needing an
eyepatch just that i scratched out from
a flurkin ladies and gentlemen new
rockstar squirrel search is officially
back on it's always been on since
captain marvel i just got a little
sidetracked thinking everyone's mephisto
instead of everyone's actually a scroll
but i'm gonna break down everything you
need to know about this series this
video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business secret invasion was a
2008 crossover storyline from writer
brian michael bendis from the marvel
comics in which a number of major marvel
characters are revealed as skrull
imposters it devolves into a sprawling
conspiracy in which everyone asks who do
you trust the storyline begins after the
events of annihilation actually begins
after house of m in which heroes of
earth get a bit weakened by what the
scarlet witch thrust upon the universe
and then the skrull empire led by their
leader varenke identifies earth as primo
real estate and begins infiltrating the
ranks of all of earth's organizations
including the illuminati and then later
on the avengers the young avengers
everybody the conspiracy begins to open
up when who they thought was elektra
ends up being a scroll imposter and
during that autopsy led by hank pym and
reed richards hank pym reveals to have
been a scroll we also find out that
black bolt was a scroll spider woman was
a scroll dum-dum dugan was a scroll
edwin jarvis was a scroll everybody a
scroll and i'm okay telling you these
characters because most of these
characters are not currently in the mcu
so it's gonna be a different lineup of
reveals who are actually scrolls it's
actually our man nick fury who uncovers
this conspiracy the early days of the
invasion and a prelude comic when he
tales
would you know it our new friend
valentina allegra defontaine now in the
mcu julie louis dreyfus as val i'm not
sure if she's gonna be a scroll per se
she seems to be more attached to uh
thunderbolts or dark avengers team being
assembled with elena bulova us agent
john walker potentially with abomination
as well but what's so cool about the
storyline is at some point in the
madness every major marvel character in
a political figure gets mimicked by a
scroll imposter black widow and hawkeye
actually prove to be pretty essential in
solving the crisis because they find out
that when you shoot someone mortally
injure them then their skrullness gets
revealed now in the mcu squirrels first
appeared in captain marvel that was set
mostly in the year of 1995 the squirrels
were revealed to have been hidden in
earth's orbit on a space station powered
by the tesseract and when the cree came
to attack captain marvel finished them
all off well not all of them just the
ones who were attacking earth and then
she led the squirrel refugees to some
unknown destination however i've always
pointed out there was one scroll getaway
from the one that captain marvel chased
on the train we never know from that
movie's plot what happened to that
long-lost scroll and then since then
skrulls have appeared of course in
spider-man far from home who we thought
was nick fury and maria hill in that
movie were actually the skrulls talos
ben mendelson's character and his wife
sorin while nick fury was on board a
squirrel space station what we thought
might have been attached to sword coming
out of juanavision we don't know if the
sword operation in that show is
connected to what nick fury was doing
however in the post-credits scene of
wandavision there was one skrull
operative who basically recruited monica
rambo and said that someone up there
wants to visit her presumably referring
to nick fury so sword may have been in
connection to what the squirrels were
actually doing however hayward in one
division probably would not have known
about that division of sword if it was
under sword's umbrella skrulls showed up
again in loki there was one tracksuit
scroll who was being checked in to the
front desk minor spoiler warning for
eternals in the middle of the movie
there was a vast montage narrated by
aeroshem to cersei and at one point he
talks about the deviants who got out of
his control on different worlds showing
what looked like a native population of
an early evolutionary link of scrolls in
marvel lore the reason squirrels were
the dominant species of that planet and
were so hated by the creek is that they
actually evolved from the deviant
bloodline of that planet so in these
late 2021 titles i think we should keep
our eyes peeled for scroll imposter
showing up in the mcu so it seems like
these days everyone is quitting their
jobs and just starting their own
business right and if you're one of
those people or want to be one of those
people you need a great website
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence for
your business squarespace lets you
present members only gated content
connect your social media accounts
present video content and all the other
cool features to give you a super cool
super functional website for your hobby
or your business squarespace will even
sell you a url collect the emails of
interested folks and send custom
newsletters to keep them up to date on
what you're doing and all the cool new
business stuff that you're up to so head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's
squarespace.comrockstars for 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
in my breakdown of eternals i pointed
out how a character like karoon the
reason why he was so loyal and so okay
with the weirdness of kingo and the
reason why he thought a deviant corpse
was beautiful this guy is an oddball i
think he's a pretty decent suspect as a
scroll the fact that this girl we saw in
loki was wearing a tracksuit now we have
the tracksuit mafia in hawkeye one of
those guys could be a scroll imposter
for a long time i thought sharon carter
could have been a scroll but it seems
like coming out of falcon winter soldier
they're going in a completely different
direction with her character however
looking at characters like maria hill
right these shadowy government operators
who've just been around forever that
brings characters like val back into the
possibility of being a scroll but again
val there's just a lot going on with her
to add scroll to that list too just
putting a hat on a hat on a hat on a hat
i think we should all keep our eye on
hank pym just because in the secret
invasion storyline of the comics hank
pym being revealed as a scroll was such
a mind blower he's an old dog been a
part of shield for a long time it's a
kind of wacky thing i could imagine
michael douglas totally committing to
also characters like happy hogan who is
kind of what jarvis was in the secret
invasion comics another guy who's been
around for a long time i could totally
imagine john favreau committing to that
reveal let's also keep in mind that at
the end of captain marvel there was a
little girl who was uh taylor's daughter
who was playing uno with the young
monica rambo and monica rambo
complimented her eyes and there was that
interesting moment in captain marvel
where taylors told her to turn away and
she happened to see some cree soldiers
being killed it felt like a little
character moment for who that character
would become is that going to be future
varanki time will tell but i just love
this shot of grizzled nick fury letting
the beard grow out however is this nick
fury because this isn't how he looked in
the far from home post credits scene
could this be his scroll imposter talos
back on earth because the scratch the
injured eye is totally something a
squirrel could mimic also i'm curious
how much this show is going to delve
into the whole idea of super squirrels
squirrels who can replicate the
superpowers of others i think this
show's gonna be a bigger political
conspiracy thriller that just deals with
who people we already knew might have
been squirrel imposters since the
beginning it's also worth remembering
that in the mcu skrulls are not the
universally evil bad guys that they are
in the comics characters like taylor
sorin their kid their group of refugees
were actually good guys in the captain
marvel story so while there may be other
divisions of skrulls who are bad guys
who are trying to infiltrate and weaken
earth there's going to be a middle
ground group of cooperative squirrels
who are good guys who might have
infiltrated earth for diplomatic or for
good reasons to protect us against the
evil imperialist cree who seem to be
universally a-holes in the marvel
cinematic universe so i think the slogan
of who do you trust won't just be
applied to who among you may be a skrull
but rather who do you trust to be okay
with that and between this giant
imperial war between the skrull empire
and between the korea empire which side
of that do you trust as a terran in a
broadening cosmic battlefield let me
know who in the mcu is the top scroll
suspect on your list be sure to check
out all of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love you got a lot more
analysis coming your way from all the
great announcements coming from disney
plus day so stick around thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you